so on the first trip to Australia we met
up with my buddy Latham who's got this
like bone disease where his bones break
and I gave him a tattoo a lot of people
said I did a bad job but they were wrong
this time we met up with Latham to color
in his tattoo and he mentioned that the
last time I saw him
we had thrown around the idea of maybe
getting him some luck with the ladies
his DS yeah and it just so happens that
in in Australia prostitution
is legal well we didn't know that at
first
it's like dude I I had forgotten but
back when jackass number two came out we
were shooting these uh promos for it we
actually went to a brothel like a a
whorehouse in Australia and screened
jackass number two for like all of the
the that's amazing that's so sick yeah
so I actually knew prostitution was
legal in Australia but I had forgotten
so
while I'm tattooing Latham he says oh
you know just so you know like uh I
still didn't you know and I was like oh
what are we talking about that he says
yeah
and I'm like all right well let's make
it happen
so I asked him any
I said you have any uh do what you do
best
let's find some so am I correct that you
Googled uh the city we were in which at
the time was Gladstone Gladstone
I think I said escorts escorts yeah and
it just showed up yeah and it gave me
like a couple websites and like a lot of
them were sketchy looking or all of them
were sketchy looking but I just started
dialing and texting and like every time
someone actually picked up the phone no
I I didn't I nobody answered but I was
getting replies via text and it's more
of like
yeah I'm available how long where are
you we happened to be in a hotel it was
like next door to their like principal
operating Hotel yeah right next door
right so we so so I give and and the the
service was uh it was a hundred
Australian dollars per 15 minutes yes
which is pretty epic yeah so I said hey
you know Latham uh here's 200 so you can
have a half an hour plus here's a tip
you know an extra 40 bucks yeah so go
enjoy yourself yeah you know I'll have
nothing to do with being a big header so
late them heads over next door yep
like uh as expected the lady opens up
the door Sees Latham in his wheelchair
and says Nope and shuts the door and
shuts the door when she was rude about
it too I I don't know I I think I mean
that is pretty rude just saying like yo
and shutting the door right you know uh
I mean at least I think so but I mean
but we did we did we struck out we
didn't specify what right the situation
was right so we struck out we went and
did the show that night and
um during the show and Lathan was pissed
he was just like do you believe this
[__] do you believe that happened you
believe what she did yeah
he's the best and he was like trying to
give me the money back to give to you
and I'm just like no dude you keep it
like you said the boner and he's
punching holes through walls
so so uh I we had been planning on I
think leaving like that night or early
the next morning yeah and um yeah glass
in the mirror bro to pop your yeah well
we were gonna like yeah so I I during
the show during one of my videos I'm
like I'm backstage texting hey we're not
leaving this city we're gonna get the
job done right yeah you know until late
um you know like uh stick around like
and so we stayed in Gladstone and then
the next day how many prostitutes did we
communicate with there's so many times
yeah there's maybe 10. you're buying
look what do you have to do like some
will only accept like gas station excuse
me
so yeah one guy it was probably some
[__] dude scamming me he was like
okay cool like I don't take cash because
I'm like oh we're at the theater come
through and he's like he's like great
I'm like we got the cash he's like oh I
don't take cash I take a gift card so
I'm like all right so I went to the gas
station I [__] went to the ATM got
cash
get gave the lady the money got the gift
card and then he and on the way back I'm
like yeah I got the gift card he's like
all ready that dude must have been hot
I mean I thought it was a girl you know
and he's like oh why don't you tell me
you're going to get gift cards I want an
Apple gift card I'm like well I have a
United gift card he's like well send me
the yeah so that was about so you knew
you were talking to a dude I mean I know
but like
I mean I figured because it was like a
scam no no I always watch scammer
paybacks and they make you do things on
so I figured it was a good age so then
when we finally found the actual lady
for the job
it was the next day it was the next day
and she was the only person that we're
communicating with that said call me and
oh
and holy crossed that all
of the prison pocket video like they
they don't seem like it's probably gonna
be a little bit tricky and and uh
hopefully this video doesn't just get
buried for uh for some of the stuff
we've talked about but hey what are you
gonna do yeah
um so yeah so we called her and I just
said you know I asked her hey we got a
guy Latham we wanted to take care of him
he's a virgin she's like yeah no problem
and then he says hey I I'm not used to
this kind of stuff I was like are you a
cop do I have to ask you if you're a cop
she's like no but I dressed up like one
sometimes
and then she was explaining to us the
laws right right and and uh like we've
stuck her behind uh like the not the
curtain but the the blind
yeah the deadlines yeah so you can see
just a silhouette of her explaining the
legality of prostitution yeah in
Australia and she said there's brothels
and there's freelance which are both
legal and she's the freelance version
where she has all of her licenses or
whatever she's licensed I mean it's epic
so she she was super cool about uh
explaining on you know on camera with
without her identity being revealed we
told her we wanted to have a Latham on
camera when the deed was done to see his
facial reaction
um turns out we had like three cameras
she was fine with it totally cool with
everything so it was Latham oh my God so
late so I I'm gone at this point I went
off to go and get some food or something
and
I and and I'm getting reports back like
is the deed done and uh Scott says he
nutted twice yeah I'm like wait dude
this is the greatest thing in the world
because
there was potential for this to be like
something that was kind of uncomfortable
maybe like oh we think this is going to
be a great video like oh dude like like
it's in for like it could there was
there was a possibility that it would
feel like we were kind of exploiting
Latham for for content and that like
bullying him into getting a hooker yeah
right right and Not only was that not
the case but he loved it so much that he
was finished with the whole operation
within 20 seconds he said and he had a
half an hour
so he said hey would you mind if we do
that again and and this lady was so cool
she was so sick you bet yeah yeah you
paid for the half hour why not yeah so
so then like the whole thing like over
the fact that it happened twice is is
genuinely indicative that it was not
in any way a bummer no no of course not
and he's on camera like when she walks
at the walks out like the door closes
and he Zips in his little electric
wheelchair straight over the camera and
he's like [__] yeah dude
wasn't he like sucking her titties and
slapping her butt I don't know I've not
seen the spider but is that true yeah
yeah
for sure wow I know I I did dude he's
such a legend dude I saw a still shot on
the camera just as a freeze frame where
he's holding her hair
yeah you got a little into it
yeah yeah
dude bless his heart e-commerce is the
way and that way ladies and gentlemen is
called ship station now to enjoy a
60-day free trial you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo again that is 60 days two months
of hassle-free stress-free shipping with
ship station
yeah dude